in a previous video I made about his
smile is amande where I discussed the
problem of representation I mentioned a
few notable individuals from within that
tradition and today I would like to take
a moment to dive deeper into one of
those individuals and as the title
obviously suggests I am talking about
the 11th century poet traveler and
missionary philosopher Nasser hosts all
throughout Ismaili history his perhaps
the most well known representative
living at a time when the fatima dynasty
was ruling from egypt and thus when the
Smiley's were arguably at the height of
their power who sorrow is especially
interesting because he can serve as a
sort of miniature example of the general
ideas and philosophies of these Smiley's
even if of course that tradition does
have a lot of inner diversity if you
want a more thorough introduction to a
smile is Amit self I suggest you watch
my previous video on the subject and I
will leave a link to it in the
description but in the general sense his
smile ISM is a what's a branch of Islam
and specifically of the Shia variety and
like other Shias they believe that the
descendants of the Prophet Muhammad are
his rightful spiritual successors and
those have the right to interpret his
teachings known as Imams the Smiley's in
particular split off from the other
major group of Shias known as the eighth
National Twelver Shias over a conflict
of succession after the death of the
fifth imam ja'far as-sadiq the smileys
later rose to political power with the
advent of the fatima dynasty in the
tenth century which ruled from Cairo in
Egypt which is a city that they actually
founded and named and in which the
caliphs of this Empire this dynasty was
also the Imams the descendants of the
prophets and thus the spiritual
authority for the entire Ismaili
community at around this time they also
appeared a number of notable
philosophers and theologians in this
tradition that started to develop what
will become known as a very
characteristic is Smyly philosophy and
theology these notable philosophers
include names like Hamid a dinky Romani
abou Jakub Alcides Thani and of course
nos and who saw himself
Naser who Sarah was likely born in 10-4
ad in Horace on and in a city in what is
today Tajikistan and he seems to have
been born into rather comfortable
environment and he was rather well-off
for most of his life he was or he became
very highly educated in a number of
fields not just the traditional
religious sciences like Quran and hadith
but also Natural Sciences astronomy
mathematics logic and especially the
Greek philosophers and he also studied
of course the Muslim philosophers like
al Kindi Al Farabi and his near
contemporary eben Cena he was very
successful in his early career as well
he actually worked as a scribe and an
economic adviser or an economic scribe
for the seljuk sultanate Hassan and now
it should be remembered that all the
information we have about nos and
hustlers life comes from his own
writings and even those writings are in
fragments and so everything should of
course be taken with a grain of salt but
nonetheless he does boast about how much
of a good reputation he had and how
successful he was in his career as one
often does but something happened to
good old NASA at the age of 42 when he
suddenly had a spiritual crisis as seems
to be pretty common at around this time
but it seemed that up until this point
in his life he had lived a pretty
luxurious and excessive life and he
wasn't exactly among God's best children
according to his cultures standards in
fact he writes that during periods of
his life he used to be constantly drunk
on wine but at 42 is something happened
as he describes in his poetry when the
heavens had measured out forty-two years
of life to me my rational soul began to
search for wisdom this realization came
through a dream that led nasod hosted
ought to change his ways and he started
to travel around the greater Middle East
looking for wisdom and an answer to his
spiritual longings during these travels
he among other things did the Hajj or
pilgrimage to Mecca several times and
visited many other sort of significant
parts of the Muslim world
the time but it was when he arrived in
Egypt in Cairo that his prayers were
finally answered because here he came
into contact with the fatimids and after
a stay of around three years he had
wholeheartedly accepted his smile ISM as
his Creed during his stay in Egypt he
became even more educated within fields
like philosophy natural science and
theology and especially in the specific
doctrines of the Smyly faith to the
point that he was appointed the title of
dye which means something like a
missionary for the faith and and after
this he was also then after three years
sent back to his home region in Persia
to be what's known as a Hodja which is
like a chief missionary
for that entire region and he seems to
have been rather successful at spreading
these smiley faiths as well
perhaps a bit too successful because
after a couple of years he became
severely under the attack of a lot of
these Sunni authorities who would
consider him a heretic basically to the
point that he had to flee and go into
hiding in a town called ba da Xiong and
which also he later he died somewhere
between the Year ten seventy seven to
ten eighty eight we don't actually know
for sure and now said who sorrow is
still remembered and revered today and
not just within a smile ism a lot of his
works are read and studied to this day
for example he wrote an account of his
travels around the world a sort of
travel by biography I called the safari
nama which is still read in Iran today
and it's considered one of the most
authoritative sources on medieval Muslim
culture he was also a very celebrated
poet probably one of the most famous and
loved poet in the entire Persian
language but lastly he was after all a
philosopher theologian and preacher of
the smiley doctrine the works of
philosophical prose and theological work
that he wrote aren't perhaps as widely
read as his other works but they are of
special interest to us today among these
works of philosophical prose are titles
like Raja Deen
the face of religion the sod and Musafir
in the the travelers provision and
lastly a book called the jami al hikmah
tain and this last book will be the
focus of this video going forward jami
al hikmah tain literally translates to
something like the union of the two
wisdoms a translation of which has
recently been published in in
association with the Institute of
Ismaili studies and industries
translation by Eric Ormsby
it is rather translated as two wisdoms
reconciled and under the main heading of
between reason and revelation in order
to get sort of attempt to get closer to
the original purpose and meaning of that
title and I recently read his
translation which inspired me to make
this video and so you should keep in
mind that all of the information I talk
about here is based on that translation
in that book it is thought that the jami
and hikmah tain is the last work written
by my master hos from the last major
work somewhere around the year 1070 and
thus it represents for a lot of people
the culmination or the pinnacle of his
philosophical thought the structure of
the book is as a series of commentaries
on a poem by a portly unidentified
individual named MIDI bin Hasaan au jus
Johnny a poem which includes many
questions ranging from philosophical and
scientific questions on the nature of
the world to questions of creation
revelation language prophecy and even
some really strange questions like one
where he asks why male babies turn their
faces upward when they're born while
female babies turn their face downward
or why people in Tibet can get fevers
and and literally the question if the
chicken or the egg came first
I'm not kidding that is actually a
question addressed in this book and so
Nasser host was commentary sort of
serves as answers to these questions
asked by the poet the main point of the
work as stated by host ro himself and as
the title suggests is to reconcile or
argue for a harmonious synthesis of
philosophical knowledge and therefore
things like natural science with
religion and revelation of the Islamic
faith Nasser justo is clearly a big fan
of knowledge and science and considers
this book as a blessing to thee let's
say less informed people in his own
words if it is justice to condone an
injury against a person who has been
wronged then it is even greater justice
to convey knowledge to the ignorant for
ignorant is manifest injury if it is in
our power to give some portion of what
we possess of this to the needy that is
an act of beneficence whose role makes
it clear in the book and like many of
his previous Muslim philosophers had
that scientific and philosophical
knowledge can only benefit the Muslims
and is complementary to the religious
knowledge as opposed to being harmful to
it as many of his contemporaries would
sometimes claim if they were hostile to
philosophy in fact early on he presents
a scathing critique of what he calls the
literal-minded scholars or jurists who
would criticize any sort of scientific
inquiry today the self-styled jurist of
the religion of Islam say if someone
states the day becomes apparent with the
rising of the Sun or I know which star
is moving and which is fixed for example
he's considered a kaffir or unbeliever
they have chosen ignorance over
knowledge and persist in claiming that
the how and the why of creation are not
our business instead who sort of argues
that human curiosity as to the how and
why of things are part of our divinely
given nature and what sets us apart from
the rest of creation by means of
demonstrative intellectual analogy we
can state that the creation of knowable
things as well as the placement within
man of his soul in quest of knowledge
along with that soul's urgent zeal and
craving to keep searching out the how of
things is such that God in the process
of creation says to every soul ask and
consider why it is as it is and do not
imagine that this creation is in vain
thus he has composed this work in order
to argue for the value of scientific
knowledge Allah
side religion to be a beacon of light
among the darkness of the ignorant after
this short mission statement he then
goes on to start answering the questions
of the poem and the book of us goes
through almost any imaginable subject in
the very first chapter called on the
proof of the creator's existence with
the discussion of his oneness in several
discourses he comes in hot right away
with a discussion on theology and the
very nature of God he lists different
schools of theological thought within
Islam and sort of ranks them according
to which is the best and the worst out
of them the first group he mentions he
simply called the prattling literalists
or the hush Wien and he describes them
as the people who read the Quran
literally
thus describing anthropomorphic
qualities to God so for example if the
Quran states that God as a hand or a
face they claim that he indeed has a
hand and a face much like a creature
does and this is the height of ignorance
to who's wrong and he basically calls
them out as stupid and ignorant and
irrational it is probable that this
school that he's talking about refers to
what we sometimes called the
traditionalists and the school of people
like had they been handbell for example
he then discusses to other groups the
kara meit's a school which we know very
little of today and the Motta's illa one
of the most famous early schools of
theology and he critiques both of their
views on the attributes of God and calls
them basically polytheists they both
affirm the existence of certain
attributes in God like knowledge life
and power but differed on how it should
be understood the Kara might argue that
the attributes are gods but are nothing
like the attribute of creatures of the
world
whilst in what Tesla argued that these
qualities don't exist as attributes at
all but as parts of God's very essence
so in in their opinion these attributes
isn't something that God has but
something that he simply is in his very
essence now now said who's Rho sort of
likes the Motta's Allah he states that
for our own part we say that there is no
approach stronger than there is among
the various schools of Islam on the sub
toheeb but even so he still isn't
entirely satisfied with this because
even a single essence that has certain
attributes as part of itself implies a
multiplicity and that does also
compromises the absolute oneness of God
the Smiley's in Nasik Lucero apply
instead a extremely negative theology
where nothing at all it can be said
about God partly inspired by
neoplatonism were even calling him
things like powerful or living or
knowledgeable is ascribing crucially
qualities to him hosted on the Smiley's
apply a kind of double negative argument
in which they state that for example God
isn't powerful but neither is he not
powerful because even not powerful is a
category that applies to created things
and thus cannot be true for God God is
completely and utterly unknowable unlike
anything in the world or anything we can
possibly conceive or imagine quote now
we have shown clearly on what grounds it
is wrong to describe God by such
attributes as ignorance and
powerlessness not because they are
unseemly but because they are attributes
of creatures as well as that it is wrong
to ascribe the opposites of such
attributes such as knowledge and power
to him glory be to him he is exalted on
the grounds that these two are
creaturely qualities there are other
very clear examples of his smiley
leanings throughout the book he applies
a very esoteric reading or
interpretation to a wheel of a lot of
Quranic sections for example like in the
story of Noah and the Ark that he
interprets in that's a kind of metaphor
rather quote Noah's Ark is not a thing
of wood but the prophet's household
Noah's Flood is not of water but instead
of ignorance and waywardness other
stories such as that of God destroying
nations of people for sinning are not to
be read literally either since everyone
including the Prophet dies and thus
death can't be the actual punishment
that God wishes upon these people
several other examples show how he takes
Quranic ideas or concepts and interprets
them in allegorical ways and also places
them within a neo platonic philosophical
framework if it is asked what is
paradise
reply that it is a world of spirits and
a mine of delights and if it is asked
what is hell we say that is a mine of
Agony's and torment if it is asked what
the gathering is that is the gathering
of resurrected souls in front of God on
the day of judgment we reply that it is
the Assembly of particular souls in the
presence of a universal soul thus he
seemingly clearly denies any form of
physical bodily resurrection and also
interprets the paradise in Hell of the
afterlife as sort of spiritual states of
the soul rather than physical places
he further speaks about concepts like
the universal intellect prime matter and
other terms that showcase the huge
influence that Neoplatonism has on a
smiley theology as explained in my
previous video Lucero talks about
revelation through the language of neo
platonic metaphysics as well and
identifies God's book that is the Quran
as the very substance of the universal
intellect itself and that the Prophet
Muhammad is a mediator between the
subtle world and the dense world through
his direct access to the world of the
intellect enabling him to read God's
inscription directly and then sort of
convey that information to the people
even though the book celebrates
philosophical knowledge and what we
would call science today it was after
all written in the 11th century and so
it isn't without its problems by today's
standards a lot of the science in the
book is violently inaccurate and
old-fashioned and and there is also
certain discussions moral aspects that
one might find as problematic in certain
ways but the same parts of the book are
also kind of funny in a way one of my
favorite sections from the entire book
is when the poet asks the question
something like how come the sun's rays
can't penetrate the moon's surface
during an eclipse
since the moon's surface is clear as
glass - which Nasser who so basically
says because the moon's surface isn't
clear as glass
Lucido kind of has this very
self-assured and critical tone in a lot
of cases which makes for some very
comical sections especially when the
information he is so assured of
is wrong too if this in this case it
wasn't but in other sections that is
sometimes the case in general this book
is fascinating to read and the present
translation is good as far as I can tell
obviously don't know Persian but it
seems to be a good translation and it's
easy to read granted that you have some
basic knowledge of medieval philosophy
and my guess is la McPhee ology it
presents a strong argument for the
reconciliation of science and religious
learning a point that seems highly
relevant today and further serves as an
interesting artifact and a window into
medieval Muslim philosophy and the
doctrines of these smileys in particular
if you're interested in the subject I
highly recommend you pick this book up
and give it a read Nasser justo is a
very interesting figure
he's a very significant figure
historically both to the Islamic world
and to our world heritage but what do
you think of him do you think any of
these ideas are good or are they crazy
have even ever heard of Nasser whose row
before feel free to leave a comment or
continue this discussion in the comments
and I will see you next time
[Music]
[Music]